Tyler and I headed across town for the
first ever Grio Awards where he dropped
some Janet Jackson collab news are you
doing another why did we get married if
if Janet and Jill Scott say yes waiting
for them to say it also breaking news
backstage Fast and Furious star Tyrese
Gibson and comedy icon honoree Keenan
Thompson we're getting really close on
Good Burger too oh you know it all right
we're gonna figure out when you know the
pocket of time will be a shooter but I'm
it's gonna happen this might be an
exclusive I hope I don't nobody off but
the Super Bowl is going to have the
world premiere of The Fast 10 trailer
and it's going to be much longer of a
trailer than usual we bought to really
[Music]
television icon winner Queen Latifah and
Kim Coles gave us a living single
reunion on the red carpet Kim told us
the cast has an epic text chain and a
reboot could be in the works we all
still look good we all still like each
other and uh hello why not working with
people like Kim Cole's Kim Fields Erica
Dylan is single doing The Equalizer
right now having people connect with it
you know see you on the streets come
naming their kids after you that's
tripping too
Latifah also hit the stage with Fantasia
Yolanda Adams and fellow honorees
Jennifer Hudson and Patti LaBelle who
told us the queen had to be talked into
singing Queen said no Patty I don't sing
I said you'll sing tonight
but when Yolanda and Fantasia and uh
Jennifer said yes but Queen had to be
forced Byron Allen created the event
that celebrates black excellence in all
Fields the show will Air later this year
on the grill Channel I want my kids to
meet the 13 year old girl that got
accepted into Mexico maybe it might help
with me saying to them hey
just do your homework
[Music]